the downtown summerlin parade of
mischief returns this halloween season
the spooktacular event starts tomorrow
bianca holman is live in summerlin to
tell us more about it it's feeling like
halloween this morning bianca good
morning
hey good morning sherry you see i got on
a little sweater it's a little chilly
out here but not too chilly for these
zombies and this uh again spooky couples
that are out here about to throw out
down some moves so i'm joined by haley
mason with downtown summerlin parade of
mischief it's back we are excited
something great for families to venture
into absolutely so we are so excited to
bring the second animal parade of
mischief presented by select health
every friday and saturday in october at
7 p.m yeah so this is great family fun i
mean we got a lot of things out across
las vegas we've got haunted hotels and
houses and we've got you know things
that will really
you know knock your socks off because
they're scary but this is mild this is
for the family correct you know this is
all family friendly you know come on
down bring your family enjoy some dinner
and celebrate halloween all month long
yeah and so in addition to the
performance because we've got some great
youth performers from las vegas
they've been again bringing great uh
talent here for the past two years
correct so we work with best agency we
cast all local kids they've been
rehearsing in the streets all week long
and we're so excited to present them
yeah and candy is there going to be
kitty at the parade there got to be some
candy corn in there for the kids yep
we'll have some pre uh performance that
you can get some candy so get here early
get your spot on the street and enjoy
the parade yeah so grab your costume
great things happen here in downtown
summerlin and of course there's
something else we want to tell you about
something that you can enjoy the weekend
of halloween we got those details coming
up in the next half hour and these goons
and goblins and zombies they're rocking
out okay we're going to send it back to
you guys in the studio